cet enregistrement date du 28 décembre
et c'est le propriétaire du château
qu'il a réalisé dans les combles au
moment d'une grosse averse le bruit de
la pluie tombant dans les bassines
révèle l'urgence des travaux à munich
dans cette aile sud construite aux 15ème
siècle alors écoutez là on se trouve ici
dans une ancienne chambre de bonne du
château et on a aussi le du temple la
filtration d'eau qui vient tout pourrir
alors la fois les plâtres le bois on a
de l'affaissement on à l'arrivée des
champignons également puisque on crée un
environnement favorable notamment à la
mérule qui est apparu dans le château
cette année donc là on a un état de
critique au niveau du bâtiment à
l'extérieur de grandes bâches ont été
installés pour ralentir les dommages
causés par les intempéries mais les
ravages du temps sont de grande ampleur
et sont chaque jour plus préoccupant et
on voit sur les chevrons notamment le ce
champignon cas par r je pense pas que ce
soit de la mérule ça mais c'est vraiment
pas conseillé ça donc là il est vraiment
temps d'intervenir
un chantier a débuté ici à l'automne et
doit se poursuivre pendant encore près
d'une année
la facture totale est supérieure à 800
milles euros en grande partie payée par
une aide exceptionnelle de l'état met un
coup de pouce de mécènes est nécessaire
pour boucler la très onéreuse opération
et on doit retrouver 74 mille euros pour
terminer clore notre notre budget c'est
une somme très importante et à ce jour
on est déjà 70 % de la collecte ce qui
est une chose absolument remarquable on
a des centaines dardoise qui ont été
prises par les gens ça à peu près 30
euros le prix moyen d'une ardoise alors
on invite à aller sur la fondation du
patrimoine et on va inscrire leur nom
comme ça et ce nom sera posée balla
derrière nous ainsi chaque modeste mais
c'est n'entrera dont la longue histoire
du château de meung-sur-loire une
ancienne résidence des évêques d'orléans
âgés de plus de 800 ans